[Music]
as we all know by now they are more than
17 channels will appear or a mentioned
most of us Godzilla king of the monsters
these talents are truly enormous in size
their height as well as a physiology are
adapted to extreme conditions that make
conventional weapons merely a nuisance
and their eyes
so the question stands which started
appear at first on earth and whether
they are tyrants that are as old or even
older than Godzilla it was stated that
these talents are the original
inhabitants of planet Earth and we
humans only evolved recently as compared
to them so which titles appear at first
on earth and which want some newcomers
let's find out in this list dedicated to
12 the Titans whose time and we can
estimate since these Titans are original
legendary monsters and no official dates
were given of their origin we can imply
by the biology and their evolution in
relation to species of animals that are
akin to them number 12 gong-gong was
still an adult an API guide you when
showed in 2017 movie Kong Skull Island
it is set in the 1970s right after the
Vietnam War even as an ape eating
puberty his size was already a hundred
four feet tall and was set to weigh 158
tons but must have been at least a
thousand tons so given the time frame of
his growth core must have been born in
the early 20th century or at least the
late 19th century
number 11 behemoth behemoth was a giant
Island that was half mammoth half sloth
also known as mapinguari to the native
brazilians given his mammalian design
this title must have evolved from the
other mammals being exposed to radiation
but not before other reptilian diamonds
which all came up during the age of the
dinosaurs number 10 Matra
mater is an ancient moth goddess that
resides in the tropical paradise infant
island but in most of us she was fought
in the Yunnan Province of China she must
have been a newcomer but her species
have had a symbiotic link with Godzilla
species since the Permian age although
the motto that appeared in the king of
the mosses hatch in 2019 her essence or
her immortality stretches way over to
the Permian Age namana I'm a nine
Ghidorah the living extinction event he
has been in many cave paintings and has
been depicted by prehistoric human
civilizations as the cause of worldwide
cataclysmic events so it stands to
reason that Ghidorah masa has well been
the cause for extinction of the
dinosaurs 66 million years ago but a
true age of this tyrant will never be
known as he came from outer space nah
Marie Rodin the pterodactyl Thailand at
the starscream of this universe must
have appeared during the early
cretaceous or late Jurassic period which
would conform to the emergence of this
pterodactyl Arkansas's during that time
line number seven michaela and baby this
title is a sauropod dinosaur Titan who
was discovered in South Sudan and
imprisoned by Moana he has been the
source of a lot of folklore among the
countless people residing in Central
Africa his sauropod dinosaur relatives
all appeared during the early Jurassic
period over 200 million years ago
number 6 Leviathan the Leviathan is also
another dinosaur / Plescia saw Titan
which was the source of all the Loch
Ness monster ticklin he was discovered
by monarch and contained in a facility
in the lake of Loch Ness itself but his
original self as well been the same or a
bit earlier than Micaela in baby number
5 Scylla Scylla is another Titan that
appear coming out of an oil field in
Sedona Arizona but regarding her
evolution
she must have been a very early tyrant
or evolved later on in the Late
Cretaceous period owing to the fact that
Arizona in that time was submerged
beneath the shallow sea and Scylla was a
semi aquatic squid arachnid Titan
number 4 Godzilla Godzilla represents a
technological hubris of man arousing the
vengeful angry of nature and he was an
obvious metaphor for the atomic bombs
drop in Japan and the end of World War
two but in most of us he has been
roaming the earth for millions of years
and he must have evolved way over in the
Permian age along with Matra species
either he himself or his ancestors must
have been guardians of this plant ever
since
number 3 Methuselah Methuselah has been
dubbed by monarch as the oldest of the
Titans and based on carbon dating
has been confirmed to be thousands of
years elder to both Godzilla and
Ghidorah the true age hasn't been shown
but based on his reptilian design he
might have as well evolved due to
effects by radiation during the Permian
age number to MU 2 prime this monstrous
piece was shown in Godzilla aftershock
comics and was said to be the precursor
of the mutant subspecies that appeared
in Godzilla 2014 this Titan was dubbed a
damaged engine mushi and was way bigger
than the other Muto's but regarding her
age she must have been also the Godzilla
as it was teased that she could have
been the one that implanted immune eggs
discovered in the fossil remains of a
child
that must have been an ancestor to
Godzilla himself number one Dagon the
number one spot goes to the deceased
ancestor of the big G himself his name
was mentioned as Dagon in some way I'm
not kidding
this ancient Godzilla like creature was
the original king of the monsters until
he was caught up in a battle with the
muta prime and she managed to impregnate
him with a Mewtwo eggs which would
eventually cause his demise nevertheless
Dagon is thought to be at least on least
on par or earlier than muta Prime in
origins so stay tuned and subscribe for
other related content on all that is
kaiju monsters and Titans
Heather notification bell for regular
and actual notifications